[Applauso]
[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti oggi parliamo di
passione passione talento quando si
incontrano sono un dono per pochi e
generano cose strordinarie in tutti i
campi
qualcuno però per arrivare all'obiettivo
sceglie il sentire della vacanza che
genere di nvidia indifferenza e
ipocrisia pochi gli risponde successo
molti lo subiscono per necessità
l'obiettivo si può anche raggiungere più
velocemente
io ho scelto il sentire della fiducia
perché genera amore pazienza e rispetto
coinvolge più persone motivate
il cammino è più lento ma ti porta
sicuramente più lontano esempio 30 anni
fa anni fa ho incontrato un ragazzo
vittorio cavirani un talento non
misurabile nella tecnica ma con la mia
stessa passione ci siamo capiti al volo
oggi è mio socio e stiamo portando le
nostre aziende competere a livello
internazionale con grandi successi
il nostro modo di essere ci aiutava
anche superare grandi ostacoli come
quando a fine nel 90 abbiamo venduto la
nostra azienda un grande gruppo
maggioranza permette di tranquillità il
dalle 80 persone per crescere in un modo
più tranquillo ci siamo sbagliati ma
siamo stati un auto posto rispettando i
patti si chiede nel 2003 sono stato
convocato una grande riunione strategica
non ho ascoltato i loro consigli mi
doveva vestire ci sono nato così allora
hanno chiesto chi ero tanto no speak
english le uniche tre parole che sapeva
un po in inglese non ha richiesto come
pensavo di gestire un'azienda senza
sapere l'inglese e gli ho detto che per
gli assi le aziende bisogna avere delle
grandi idee le libri si comprano ecco
perché noi oggi siamo il più di 700 e
loro purtroppo si sono sciolti come neve
al sole
[Applauso]
sempre sempre quella fiducia per noi è
molto facile trasmettere le nostre
passioni a tutti la passione con la
fiducia ci aiuta moltissimo a fare una
corsa venaria delegare cose che sanno
fare in pochi non stiamo delegando tanti
nostri giovani
negli ultimi quattro anni abbiamo il
sito oltre 300 ragazzi collaborando con
le scuole del territorio dell'unità
d'italia anche estere
mescolando culture competenze una cosa
fantastica io definisco un prato sempre
in fiore di primavera e ortaggi questi
ragazzi mi incontrano e mi chiedo se un
con un sogno nel cassetto
io dico degli abitanti dei cassetti ma
nessuno particola un colore diverso
perché lo riconosco sempre quando sono
un po triste lo tiro e già sarebbe
scritto dai capitan non smettere mai di
sognare più bello nel cassetto più
importante e devo dire che due anni fa
alcuni anni fa ho ridato un suo
fantastico io ho sempre avuto un
rapporto non bellissimo con mio figlio è
sempre difficile dei rapporti con i
figli quando un imprenditore è successo
però con fiducia delegato una cosa che
mai pensavo di fare o delegato alla
comunicazione e il marchio delle mie
aziende
a lui mi ha fatto il suo team oggi è
riconosciuto da tutta struttura come un
grande valore aggiunto
lo fa molto meglio di come lo facevo io
io sono molto contento per lui perché
vedono ai suoi occhi alla grande
soddisfazione e la motivazione con
passione di fare un lavoro che gli piace
e soprattutto e sul sentiero giusto per
creare un giusto futuro per lui per la
sua famiglia e per tutti quelli che
lavorano con lui io il mio tempo
definito vi auguro a tutti un grande
futuro è un grande in bocca al lupo
tratti
[Applauso]
dovete sapere che io e il capitano
abbiamo avuto una piccola discussione
sulle argomentazioni di questa giornata
ragione e passione perché non vi nego
che la passione era un argomento per me
è molto stimolante poi però non ci ho
messo molto tempo a capire che avevo
poche possibilità di uscire vincitore da
questa discussione quindi cosa volete
che vi dica me ne sono fatto una ragione
perché adesso entriamo un po nel vivo di
questo argomento con alcune domande
la prima è quante volte nella vostra
vita avete lottato con il coltello tra i
denti per avere ragione io personalmente
mentre lo stringevo me li sono anche un
po rock e ogni tanto oppure quante volte
avete avuto rimpianti per non aver
lottato per la vostra ragione o ancora
quante volte avete raggiunto questa
gonna agognata ragione ma questo non vi
ha dato felicità e non vi ha fatto
raggiungere il vostro obiettivo
e se non vi ritrovate in nessuna di
queste tre io credo che forse è arrivato
il momento di diventare i protagonisti
della vostra vita ma adesso faccio un
passo indietro
un passo indietro che mi porta a una
considerazione prima ancora di cercare
la nostra ragione sarebbe molto
interessante fare un esercizio che è
quello di provare a metterci nei panni
degli altri abbandonare o abbandonare
almeno in parte il nostro egoismo dicono
che un pizzico non faccia male
abbandonare i pregiudizi ecco quelli a
mio parere sono molto più pericolosi per
arrivare alla nostra ragione ma
arrivarci con più delicatezza nero
impulsività meno e invadenza e già
questo passo potrebbe darci una mano
veramente importante
a migliorare il nostro rapporto con
questa maledetta
sì questa maledetta ragione che anche se
ce l'hai e non te la dà nessuno ti serve
a poco oa nulla magari serve equilibrio
un po come con l'orgoglio che su una
scala da 1 a 10
io credo sia buono fino a 5 dopo il 5 e
può portarci sofferenza e può anche
farci perdere o portanti importanti
opportunità
vedete io e mio padre non siamo sempre
andati d'accordo e se oggi mi guardo
indietro con un pizzico di maturità in
più rispetto ai miei vent'anni devo dire
che il 99 per cento delle volte che
abbiamo discusso lui aveva ragione ma
questa ragione ha quasi causato una
rottura tra di noi e poi invece successe
una cosa incredibile
un giorno vengo chiamato a rapporto e
vado e lui mi dice guarda ho solo figlio
e ho pensato che ricostruire il nostro
dialogo il nostro rapporto si è più
importante del lavoro in azienda
e poi mi dice anche che mi darà una mano
a fare quello che mi piace
che tradotto nella mia testa è stato
seguire le mie passioni seguire i miei
sogni
volete sapere che reazione ho avuto beh
black out totale
questo a causa team è uno shock non mi
aspettavo un approccio completamente
diverso
ho avuto circa un mese di confusione
mentale e alla fine di questo mese di
libero arbitrio
ho deciso di
rientrare a lavorare in azienda questo
percorso poi mi ha dato anche
l'opportunità di creare una mia realtà
ma soprattutto mi ha dato l'opportunità
di scoprire una cosa che a me piace
moltissimo che quella di condividere le
mie esperienze con altre persone perché
da questa condivisione da questo
confronto o valore o contrasto o
cambiamento veramente moltissimi stimoli
che per me sono molto molto utili per
crescere quindi vele di passione
onde di ragione perché perché io credo
che questi due elementi queste due
sensazioni per dare il massimo debbano
essere buoni compagni di viaggio debbano
parlare l'uno con l'altro l'uno ascolta
l'altro e viceversa in un equilibrio le
vele di passione infrangono le onde
della ragione ma nello stesso tempo le
accompagnano le rispettano perché può
essere pericoloso altrimenti per la
nostra imbarcazione per il nostro
capitano sottovalutare il mare dove
navighiamo
se pensiamo di trattarli come singoli
elementi risulta molto difficile quasi
impossibile difficile pensare a l'uno
senza l'altro quindi esisterà una
ricetta
io credo sinceramente che una ricetta
non esiste però sono convinto che per
navigare in questo mare possiamo
allenarci a cambiare in velocità il che
vuol dire flessibilità vuol dire
sperimentazione vuol dire commettere
errori non bisogna avere paura di
commettere errori gli errori ci
insegnano come migliorarci sono un po
come degli insegnanti
io credo che non esista successo senza
l'errore
per questo voglio lasciarvi con un
augurio che è quello di trovare la
vostra ragione
ma anche che la vostra ragione vada a
braccetto con la vostra passione e
soprattutto che questo possa rendervi
felici voi e il vostro prossimo
credo sia uno degli obiettivi più
importanti perdere poco tempo a
dialogare con l'infelicità ma sfruttarla
come stimolo e metro di valutazione
della felicità il mondo ha bisogno di
persone vive persone libere di
esprimersi nel rispetto difficile sì ma
faremo sempre in tempo a mio parere a
raggiungere obiettivi facili buona vita
[Applauso]
[Musica]